[Música]
whitman santa mal y estaba aprendiendo
japonés soñaba con enseñar inglés en
japón
murió hace un año en un centro de
inmigración japonés para solicitar ayuda
médica en vano
su familia vino desde sri lanka para
esta ceremonia budista
creo que el alma de mi hermana no está
en paz
les pido a todos que recen para que
pueda descansar en paz
deseo cambiar la ley para que esta
tragedia no vuelva a suceder
esta muerte se reavivó el debate en
japón sobre las condiciones de los
centros de detención para extranjeros
indocumentados
los extranjeros no vienen a japón a
morir vienen aquí a vivir
en los últimos 15 años 17 personas han
muerto en centros de detención cuando
wish me murió pensé otra vez
en realidad no me sorprendió
la hermana menor de wish man se mudó a
tokio para presentar una demanda contra
las autoridades wissmann llegó a japón
en 2017 para estudiar y se había quedado
más de lo permitido por su visa de
estudiante
esta es la foto que nos tomamos en sí
lanka
justo antes de que se fuera me tomé unas
el fin y pensé que esta sería la última
foto que podría tomar en mucho tiempo
es realmente triste
después de que le denegaran la solicitud
de asilo luisma fue encerrada en 2020 en
un centro que parecía una cárcel no
había límite legal para el tiempo de su
detención perdió 20 kilos en pocos meses
y se quejó de tener dolor de estómago
sus guardias aseguraban que mentía ni
siquiera sabía que mi hermana estaba
detenida por admiración y ni siquiera
nos dijeron que estaba enferma el motivo
por el que acudimos a la justicia es
porque mi hermana estaba enferma pero
aún no sabemos la causa de la enfermedad
de sudamérica un informe oficial
reconoció finalmente la negligencia
médica se presentó una disculpa a la
familia se castigó a los funcionarios y
se aplicaron reformas sin embargo los
centros de inmigración japoneses son
regularmente objeto de críticas
desnutrición palizas como en este vídeo
de un detenido brasileño maltratado en
i
cada año unos 10.000 extranjeros
solicitan asilo en japón pero sólo un
centenar reciben la aprobación esta
cifra contrasta con las decenas de miles
cada año en francia y eeuu mío es un
rohingya birmanos una minoría musulmana
perseguida en mianmar llegó en 2006 a
sus 20 años con una pequeña maleta su
vida apenas ha cambiado desde entonces
sigue esperando el estatuto de refugiado
y sobre todo no puede trabajar como
resultado para sobrevivir depende de las
asociaciones
pasteles mascarillas pan y en realidad
sólo vivo de esto
de lo que me dan tenía una imagen muy
positiva de japón a que me iban a
ofrecer el estatus real
francamente si volviera 16 años atrás no
vendría aquí
la tercera economía del mundo es un país
envejecido con enormes necesidades de
mano de obra sin embargo japón se niega
a abrirse a la inmigración masiva no
quiere seguir el modelo occidental por
ello los extranjeros que viven allí se
encuentran a menudo en una situación
precaria la inmigración se niega aunque
es real el país cuenta con casi 3
millones de extranjeros
antes de venir a japón no pensaba que
hubiera tantos extranjeros en el país
todos los viernes mío viene a rezar a
esta mezquita improvisada con otros
birmanos indonesios paquistaníes en su
opinión la libertad religiosa y la
seguridad son los puntos fuertes de
japón
amar es un país peligroso en el que los
musulmanes están estigmatizados
pero en japón puedes usar maquillaje e
ir donde quiera
este amigo rojilla se casó con una
birmana naturalizada ahora puede
trabajar y abrió esta tienda es el sueño
de muchos solicitantes de asilo
encontrar un trabajo pero la
administración tiene normas estrictas
acepta el 1% a veces incluso menos de
las solicitudes de asilo los
solicitantes rechazados no son enviados
a sus países por la fuerza algunos son
liberados provisionalmente con la
prohibición de trabajar otros son
detenidos en estos centros de la muerte
como los llaman los manifestantes esta
mujer de burkina faso pasó 15 meses en
uno de estos centros cuando me
detuvieron mi bebé apenas tenía un mes
solo se me permitía verlo a través de
una ventana de cristal
me negaba a hacerlo cuando salí mi hijo
ni siquiera sabía quién era yo
a finales de 2020 la 1 consideró que la
política de asilo de japón no cumplía
las normas internacionales de derechos
humanos
[Música]